now you can see here um just with two
training areas we have pretty good
results um on all those ponds C even the
the the sea which is the upper part um
got captured as water that's a pond too
yeah it's like large pond and um and and
as you usually now you you to do this
you you need to task a labeling company
in-house or or external and and tell
them and give them like literally
thousands or even tens of thousands of
training images and and they Mark all
the PS they they give you back the The
vectorized annotation data and then you
use this with your in-house machine
learning Engineers to train your AI and
we all sh cuted this now in a couple of
minutes but just me um marking toas it's
very Dynamic so if you think about it if
you were say Tesla building solar roofs
and they have a tile for solar roofs
that is like the Spanish tiles the
curved clay tiles that you see on you
know uh Spanish homes uh or
Mediterranean homes you could literally
say say hey you know what California
Arizona uh Colorado are our main markets
here's you know just some sales
executive could go in here and say these
are Spanish tile roofs in you know the
Bay Area Los Angeles San Diego those are
our highest end you know most likely to
buy a solar roof and these are the ones
that break down the most and are most
likely to and get the most benefit from
it tell me all the Spanish tile homes
that don't have solar but that do have
Spanish tile
and give me their addresses and that
person could do that in an hour or less
great example similar one um we got
which is a little bit more complex but
cila um mindset uh and and process um
some large energy utility company asking
us if we can identify potential
locations like location Scouting For
Renewables where to build gigantic wind
Parks like with this huge wind wind
turbines they know they need a certain
like um XY size of the of the area which
should not be built with some existing
buildings it should follow a certain
topology mostly flat no mountains or or
forests nearby which can Shield off the
wind and um certain minimum distance to
the next human settlement um for like
noise regulations and also there should
be an Highway closer to whatever 500
meters so they can bring in the heavy
construction Machinery to build this
wind par and we all fed this into our uh
uh basically um AI we use containers for
that to run them in lawn mower style
over large areas of the planet to
identify um potential sites for where
they can build such a wind Park amazing
yeah I mean and then you're going to be
able to do this with voice and just say
to it eventually hey you know you have
enough training data in here show me all
the places I could have I could build a
new city I just did a tweet the other
day that went viral where I talked about
hey you know when I'm president my first
order of businesses I'm going to create
10 cities and those 10 cities will have
a million homes in each I could actually
use your to say hey find me 10 locations
that could have a City Hub with 500
Apartments then 200 300 town homes in
the next ring and then 200 uh you know
th uh single family homes and make it
you know and uh that is near you know
whatever uh within 100 miles of another
city so that it could be a satellite
City to that one and boom all of a
sudden you could tell me where to put my
10 uh president Jason cities as part of
my initiative correct perfect now think
of all the hedge funds uh investing in
shopping malls identifying where they
not enough shopping malls yet yeah or
where shopping malls exist I guess it
would be interesting also the changes
you talked about how often things are
updated and satellites are updated you
tell me how how often could you update
the imagery of Taiwan in that example uh
with the satellite company you work with
do they update the entirety of that
every month every year year every day
what's the state-ofthe-art today here in
this particular case the limit is not on
our side the limit is on the image
acquisition and uh if you use satellite
um there are companies doing a daily
update of the entire planet um this
companies doing that wow which ones do
that which companies that's Planet Labs
Planet lab sure on program yeah yeah
they're not at the resolution yet like
this the the the more static uh
satellites are but this is I think
matter of time uh and also the the the
Cadence will will increase um but you
can use drones or or aial if you want to
have that and we we made an experiment
with a with a client who who wants to
hit there from a very small country I
think 12,000 square kilometers and they
want to monitor building changes like
when new buildings had been built and um
we solved this uh with like five gpus in
the cloud it took 5 hours and then the
client itself scaled it up using our
back end to thousands of machines and
they brought it down to minutes so
that's almost real time that's insane
because if you think about it if you
were doing uh and listen there's all
kinds of privacy and surveillance issues
here I know but let's put those aside
for a second and think about the
positive aspects here if you were uh
living in a country where maybe some
people were building buildings without
going through the proper channels and
making them safe you think an emerging
or Frontier Market they might be doing
that you could in
fact every morning say to your building
inspectors hey somebody's breaking
ground here there's a bulldozzer in
these seven different locations they're
building a foundation of these seven we
have permits for two so these other five
we need to make a site visit today
before they build this building that's
like literally and then they could just
stop them from building and say hey you
got to be permitted to do this and make
it safe correct exactly I think of like
um another type of how is it called
building uh violations um I recently
went to the to the Middle East to to to
the KSA and um you know yourself about
the the gigantic construction projects
they're doing their Giga projects and
yeah and and and one of the other issues
is um people are are building like crazy
and um some of them don't have the right
permit for it or built bigger than than
they than they are allowed to and uh
it's very easy to to use what we can
detect and then conflate it with some
City Planning uh cadaster or other other
existing data and find out and pick up
the ones who who who should pay more
taxes because they build more than they
allowed to yeah I mean the square
footage determines your your price so
you could actually estimate hey how did
this change over time what's the square
footage did somebody put an Adu or shed
in is it properly done you could also do
this for I know a lot of people are
studying uh deforestation or forestation
where people are planting things so you
can get a really accurate pulse on the
trees being planted that kind of stuff
so this is an internal to you have and
it's called Ora Hunter why is it called
Orca Hunter coming back to the founding
story of black Shar when we built as a
very first uh uh uh project the the
Microsoft ulator we had to develop all
of the back end all of the tooling
ourselves there was nothing and I still
think there's nothing out there like
that and for us it was the end product
was this 3D World this what initially I
called digital twin uh which we're still
working on at many great applications
but U when doing outreaches and talking
with many many potential customers we
found out all the intermediate steps we
built to come to this digital twin is
are actually products on its own and
orca is our outtake of our G special um
uh software solution and orah Hunter is
is basically this first tool we're going
to release uh December 2nd for anyone uh
who wants to license it to upload their
own images and and do this this Scribble
grayan approach oh wow so it's going to
be a SAS tool I could basically if I
have images that I acquired from
wherever I could get it from a public
satellite images I could take you know
uh old images you know that might be in
the public domain and I could upload it
and pay you a fee just to use the tool
yeah even our team uh for we did a
LinkedIn posting for Thanksgiving where
they uploaded the image of of of a pizza
and did a pizza topping detection ah the
classific yeah you don't want to get
into any of that pineapple uh
Pizza businesso business marketing is
not an easy job it's much different than
business to Consumer advertising why
well the Enterprise buying Cycles are
very long and they're filled with
decision makers and those decision
makers are going to kill your deal if
you can't get to them that's why you
need to check out LinkedIn ads LinkedIn
has amazingly but not unexpectedly
passed a billion users this includes 180
million senior Executives there's also
10 million SE Suite Executives those are
the CEOs CFOs CTO the chief strategy
officer Chief Finance officers this
means 18% of those users are the ones
who are the decision makers how do you
get to them you get to them through
Linkedin in a respectful business
environment they're ready to accept a
business message as opposed to you know
another platform where they might be
consuming cooking videos or podcasts or
political discourse no LinkedIn is about
business you want to get people where
they're in that cognitive mindset and
they're willing to accept a business-to
business message 79% of B2B content
marketers said LinkedIn ads produces the
best results for paid media this is
obvious I can tell you this is true when
you think about business you think about
LinkedIn it just exactly what comes to
mind so here's your call to action make
businessto business marketing everything
it can be and get a $100 credit towards
your next campaign by going to
linkedin.com thiswe in startups to claim
your credit linkedin.com
thisweek in startups no spaces no dashes
linkedin.com thiswe and startups for a
Hy $100 in credit terms and conditions
do
apply